alors pourquoi la seine saint denis
situé aux portes de paris reste enlisée
et dans la pauvreté alors qu'elle a tous
les atouts a priori pour décoller le
département et il stigmatise et c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes en direct
avec m'hamed kaki sociologue président
de l'association mémorielle et orange à
ses côtés alexandre vecchio journalistes
le figaro qui a grandit d'ailleurs il
faut le préciser en seine saint denis
c'est donc un département qu'il connaît
bien bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on vient de le voir dans la seine
saint denis qui est de nombreux atouts
une population jeune du dynamisme
proximité avec la capitale des projets
comme le cdg express ou encore les géo à
venir et pourtant ça reste le
département le plus pauvre de france
comment vous vous l'expliquer on
commence par vous aux 20 mètres kaki
écoutez d'abord le mot lui même le mot
stigmatisation je moi je préfère le mot
disqualification parce que le mot
stigmatisation rappelle un loader
important qui s'appelle evry hoffman qui
a travaillé sur les handicapés sur
l'asile notamment et sur comment la
stigmatisation à part assez pour les
handicapés donc ce mot la
disqualification médiatique et politique
est plus approprié pour ce département
la deuxième chose qui est très
importante c'est quand même temps c'est
un département attractif où il ya une
convoitise extrêmement importantes
notamment à travers le foncier il suffit
de voir bagnolet montreuil à toutes ces
villes qui sont autour et d'autres
ailleurs qui sont très convoités par la
bourgeoisie
entre ville de paris et donc qui veut
s'installer elle et qui fait augmenter
d'ailleurs un foncier très important
donc voyez il ya un paradoxe entre à la
fois le mot disqualification
stigmatisation comme vous ne l'avez dit
le poser la question à un mauvais
ajustement est ce que c'est un
département qui est stigmatisé faux
frêle une voix l'ajustement des raisons
pour lesquelles elles s'enliserait dans
la pauvreté alors qu'elle a peint des
tons c'était une question c'est ça alors
justement deuxième chose c'est un
département jeunes parce que le
libéreront 93 a été créé en 1968 et
savez vous que d'où vient ce chiffre et
ce chiffre 93
eh bien il nous vient de constantine une
ville en algérie c'était le numéro de la
ville de constantine en algérie dans
l'histoire coloniale voyez-vous et donc
ça a été donnée par le général de gaulle
à l'époque pour créer la
seine-saint-denis justement pour créer
ce département qui est qui était un
bastion ouvrier très important dirigée
par le parti communiste il faut le
rappeler
pendant très très longtemps et en même
temps c'est une histoire très longue du
19e siècle c'est l'industrialisation
c'est les usines c'est eux
je dirais une économie très important
qui s'installe et c'est un prolétariat à
la base donc un lieu de travail de
ressources de travailleurs portant où
les gens ont grandi en travail et en
construit un si vous voulez ce
département qui encore une fois très
convoité par la bourgeoisie
on va donner la parole à alexandre ii
vecchio ex ante vécu il ya plusieurs
idées qui ont été véhiculées par
mohammad taqi disqualification
médiatique j'ai retenu et puis
effectivement une pression immobilière
la bourgeoisie comme l'a qualifié en
tout cas on va mettre kaki qui
souhaitent s'y installer c'était
intéressant cette petite partie
historique qui rappelle que c'était
effectivement un département dans lequel
il y avait les usines
de là l'industrialisation beaucoup de
travail quelle est la réaction à toutes
ces idées on va essayer de les
structurer un peu alexandre ii vecchio
moi j'ai un forcément de réactions
négatives à ces idées là sur la
disqualification je suis un peu plus
sceptique c'est un goût un département
qui peut avoir mauvaise réputation mais
je pense parce qu'il a des aussi des
problèmes réels d'insécurité
d'intégration etc
je pense que la pauvreté elle est lié à
plusieurs choses on a parlé de la genèse
département c'est aussi un département
jeunes parce qu'ils comptent le plus de
jeunes en froid c'est toute façon la
jeunesse de manière logique et peut-être
plus pour que les gens qui sont
installés dans la vie à l'âge adulte
c'est un département qui a été de
tradition ouvrière
aujourd'hui ça reste un département
ouvriers et mai sur fond de
désindustrialisation et aussi sur fond
d'immigration
donc effectivement c'est une population
pauvre qui vient pour retrouver du
travail
au moment justement où la france subit
une désindustrialisation massive à
partir des années 70 80 et encore plus
aujourd'hui donc tout ceci explique la
pauvreté après moi je crois qu'elle est
les immigrés qui viennent ici malgré
tous c'est un c'est un progrès par
rapport à leur pays à leur pays
d'origine donc il faut relativiser
également la pauvreté je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'hommes
on peut donner aussi une meilleure image
du 93 on l'a vu pendant la crise du
corona virus il y avait beaucoup
d'autres soignants beaucoup de
travailleurs qui ont été les fameuses
première ligne qui ont été au fond après
il ya effectivement ce que je disais en
préambule ces difficultés d'intégration
ces tensions sécuritaires ces tensions
culturelles qui sont pas aussi seulement
liés
mon avis à la question sociale ça en
fait partie des questions d'urbanisme
qui commence à être réglé avec l'édile a
rappelé en banlieue mais il ya aussi
effectivement des questions de
délinquance de communautarisme de
violence voilà qu'ils soient une réalité
qu'il faut panique et je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit uniquement lié à la
pauvreté on l'a vu malgré tout un grand
effort a été fait dans la rénovation m
il ya un grand est forfait pour les
politiques sociales et médias pour ces
tensions qui sont liées à mon avis -
essentiellement un problème
d'intégration
elle me taquinait intégration tension
sécuritaire délinquance communautarisme
ce sont des bons qu'il vous faut bondir
où vous êtes d'accord avec le diagnostic
d'alexandre ii vecchio qu il ferait donc
partie des choses que l'on vend 30
juillet un petit peu ce département à
écouter
moi je n'ai pas parlé ouvre tes je vais
parler de ressources
je pense que dans ce département il ya
des richesses et ça a été dit notamment
autres à travers la jeunesse il y à des
énergies importantes qui sont comme
l'ont été dans le passé leurs parents
les gens qui ont construit et de ce
département n'est pas seulement le
produit de l'immigration c'est le
produit la classe ouvrière française
il faut le rappeler et l'immigration
fait partie de cette classe ouvrière
donc ça c'est très important
après il y a il faut parler surtout des
politiques publiques c'est à dire
comment on en est venu là les
difficultés quoi ce département d'île a
plus de difficultés que d'autres
départements il faut le rappeler on l'a
dit tout à l'heure que dès le départ
l'est parisien et notamment le 93 a été
c'est le lieu des usines c'est le lieu
du travail et c'est le lieu justement où
les par exemple à côté dans l'ouest
parisien c'était des riches qui se sont
installés dans la verdure dans les lieux
sympas comme on dit et paradoxalement
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on en est là la
vraie discussion c'est que aujourd'hui
c'est la puce
en ce public que font les services le
fond que fait la puissance publique et
l'état par rapport à un certain nombre
de problématiques que rencontrent la
jeunesse langlois notamment à travers
cette désindustrialisation et on voit
qu'il n'ya pas de corrélation se voyait
que par exemple dans une ville comme
saint denis
on s'installe des entreprises de pointe
de technologie importante ou notamment
du la question de langage de la jeunesse
pose problème est ce que on va donner on
va en profiter par derniers mois à
l'aide à la jeunesse et bab el thekil
pardonnez-moi d'un petit revient avec
vous et comme comme la réponse est assez
lent on va en profiter de ce prêtre de
liaison pour donner la parole à
alexandre ii vecchio effectivement
alexandre de vecchi on dit souvent voilà
ces jeunes qui ne sont pas toujours
employé alors même qu elle qui n'a pas
prononcé du tout le monde discrimination
mais enfin
son coach parle sur son contrôle c'est
peut-être qu'il allait certainement dire
voilà que c'est compliqué pour ces
jeunes de ce département les politiques
publiques qu'est ce que vous répondez ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ces propos
autant sur le diagnostic on pouvait te
en accord tout à l'heure pour se
rejoindre au taux majoré ou je trouve
que la puissance publique pas fait
beaucoup
malgré tout pour ce département la gelée
dit de multiples plans pour curro pour
les banlieues à chacun des d'ailleurs
nouveau monde à venir dans notre jour
viendra il ya une politique de la ville
qui est mise en place mais on s'aperçoit
alors c'est bien là la rénovation
urbaine moi je suis par contre parce que
je pense qu'il faudra améliorer les
conditions de vie effectivement des gens
l'uimm dans un meilleur cadre on vit
mieux en ce sens et sans doute que ça
facilite beaucoup de choses mais ça ne
résout pas tout d'ailleurs quand on
parle à ses habitants ont dit leur a
construit parfois des maisons du propre
des immeubles meilleur et on voit bien
que les problèmes d'insécurité et de
tensions continues
moi je ne crois pas que c'est lui à une
discrimination ce pas que l'état a été
généreux a même tenté de mettre en place
parfois des politiques de discrimination
positive
je crois que c'est lié à un problème
d'intégration d'intégration culturelle
c'est à dire la voir les codes culturels
pour demandent à avoir dans le pays et
aussi en entreprise les codes les codes
sociaux etc ces deux là dessus qu'il
faut faire un effort elle que justement
me le discours victimaire et parfois
pernicieux et contre productive puisque
quand on répète à une population qu'elle
est victime victime de discrimination et
finit par le croire et avoir du
ressentiment donc je crois qu'on doit
aussi insister sur ce qui a été fait
pour ce département pour ces populations
là et miser sur leur intelligence leur
capacité d'action sociale et
l'intégration est pas toujours les
considérer comme des victimes dix
criminels moi-même kaki et le mot de la
fin ils sont tous là la réponse parce
que ce raisonnement c'est vrai
en opposition avec un raisonnement de
victimisation est ce que c'est un début
aussi de solutions peut-être regarder ce
qui a été fait la valorisation de ce qui
est fait et puis peut-être arrêter de
regarder ces personnes comme des
victimes tout simplement écouter devenir
pas de victimation il y à des combats
que mènent les associations que mène des
jeunes en aucun cas ouverts et
responsables associatifs a parlé de
misérabilisme ou de victimisation
au contraire les gens sont dans le
combat tous les jours ou un combat pour
la dignité pour la vie est effectivement
l'enjeu libéraux 1 c'est la question de
l'emploi ce à seulement the le
saupoudrage que peut mettre en place les
pouvoirs publics ici ou là c'est la
question de l'emploi la question de
l'emploi des jeunes la question d'une
politique sur le long terme
or de ce point de vue là il ya une panne
générale et donc c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut donner de l'espoir à l'ensemble de
cette jeunesse et l'ensemble des ces
familles qui vivent là qui ne demande
qu'à une chose qui demande un travail et
d'ailleurs je le ferai je vous
rappellerai que beaucoup de gens de ces
travailleurs nyala paris et font le
travail dans les bureaux avec les plus
grande pénibilité donc la question du
travail la question de la jeunesse elle
et elle et elle est au centre de cette
affaire et on aucun cas les gens sains
pleure sur leur sort où sont ceux vctv
comédie parce que ça encore une fois
c'est un processus de disqualification
quand on dit victimisation c'est là que
l'on on disqualifie des gens moi je ne
pense pas du tout qu'il ya ça je pense
que ce que je vois autour de moi ou
alors on vit pas dans les mêmes endroits
il y a des gens qui a un qui combat pour
une dignité pour leur histoire et voyez
on parlait de l'école on est d'accord
moi je parlais des discours médiatique
qu'on entend qu'on entend parfois et
qu'ils sont parfois caricaturaux et on
parlait d'être d'associations et des
associations qui font du bon travail
des associations qui font du malheur des
gens une forme de rente et donc moi je
me méfie beaucoup de ceux qui justement
propagent ces discours ensuite je vous
rejoins en vous dites qu'il ya un
problème d'emploi qui a un problème de
désindustrialisation qui est un problème
pour la jeunesse trouver du travail mais
j'ai envie de dire que ça touche pas
seulement la jeunesse de
seine-saint-denis en réalité je vous
allez en creuse et en lozère la
puissance publique a peut-être beaucoup
moins investi que dans certains
quartiers de 7,5 me c'est pour
relativiser mais c'est pour dire qu'il
n'ya pas de discrimination qu'au
contraire les pouvoirs publics ont pris
la mesure de toutes ces choses quand il
ya un problème ce point les problèmes de
délinquance et de tensions
communautaires qui n'ont rien à voir
et là on était le perdant avec la
pauvreté merci à tous les deux désole
son arrive vraiment la fin de ce débat
m'hamed kaki désolé on vous a entendu
beaucoup tous les deux d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur wuala exactement on
continuera ce débat merci à tous les
deux en tout cas